entre les murs des grandes écuries de
versailles des lustres au design moderne
viennent éclairer un parquet versailles
et du xviiie ce bâtiment construit par
jules hardouin mansart abriter l'école
des pages du roi il est maintenant au
coeur du projet ambitieux du campus
d'excellence de versailles il aura usage
pour accueillir le campus d'excellence
sur une partie là vient d'aménager son
pilote soit 850 m² donc à campus
d'excellence qui vient absorber cinq
filières de formation cinq filières de
formation qui regroupe un large panel
des métiers du patrimoine et de
l'artisanat d'excellence comme des
tailleurs de pierre les jardiniers des
sommeliers ou encore des pâtissiers le
13 octobre prochain
les premiers élèves feront leur rentrée
ici ouvrir dans quelques salles de
formation des espaces d'expositions de
conférences d espace d'orientation et
puis des espaces de pouvoir tout pour
les artisans qui souhaiteraient venir
partager leur savoir faire orienter les
collégiens accompagnés les lycéens
former les étudiants présentaient des
savoir faire ou encore répondre aux
besoins de main d'oeuvre des entreprises
cette mise en commun de divers acteurs
entend créer un réseau un lieu et un
label au service de ses métiers
l'ambition c'est de donner un souffle
nouveau aux métiers du patrimoine de
l'artisanat et d'aider à l'insertion des
jeunes professionnels un campus qui est
encore en construction et qui va
s'étendre progressivement jusqu'en 2025
on va déployer sa sur les deux ailes
donc là on est au sein de liffré en tête
de l'aide de paris on va projeter sur
l'île de saint cloud ça va être un
chantier assez gigantesque puisqu'on va
apporter la restauration soit 6000
mètres carrés de bungie à terme et bien
ouvrir les 6000 mètres carrés du campus
avec beaucoup plus d'ateliers de travail
des laboratoires de cuisine et puis des
espaces surprenant